da und sehen mich insofern das gewünscht
ist ja okay also ich grüße ich hoffe sie
haben sich gut erholt und sind gesund
geblieben und das weiterhin auch bleiben
so wir sind jetzt machen jetzt weiter
mit dass kontinuität und politische
philosophie
ich möchte jetzt wie auch schon im
letzten in der letzten veranstaltung ein
bisschen tiefer auf die metaphysischen
fragen eingehen
nicht zuletzt weil die metaphysischen
fragen ganz gut in parallel sich
entwickeln zu den pulli politik
politologischen fragen insbesondere
jetzt heute hingerichtet möchte ich auf
leibnitz zurückgehen und im implizit
jedenfalls dass ich jetzt neben nicht im
einzelnen beschreiben aber die debatte
zwischen leibnitz und seinen gegnern vor
allem dann in dem fall die briten jetzt
newton zur frage der zuerst die infinite
sma rechnung erarbeitet gefunden hätte
aber tiefer ist dass der gegensatz
zwischen leibnitz als theoretiker der
kontinuität und und den engländern
newton hobbes und andere die eher eine
wenn man so wie atom ist ische welt
einzig propagiert haben so hat es
jedenfalls leid nicht selbst formuliert
also seine eigene position hat er im
gegensatz zum atheismus dargestellt und
leibnitz wie wir wissen sehr
einflussreich
auch die nachfolgende deutsche
philosophie auf den idealismus vor allem
kann und es baut sich aufbaut sich diese
diesem jahr gewissermaßen konnten
konfrontation auch zwischen einem so
sind wir alle drin ich glaube schon
zwischen leibnitz auch der auf der
position wie gesagt der kontinuität
metaphysisch und auch der gegenseite
zunächst einmal die briten auf der
touristischen seite das ändert sich im
19 jahrhundert weil wir auch schon
gesehen haben
endlich konnte ist es keinen gegensatz
zwischen content englisch schon
continental jedenfalls nicht in weiteren
verlauf im neunzehnten jahrhundert sind
die vertreter der diskontinuität schon
eher
kontinentale denker wie kirche gott
nietzsche und dann die wir gesehen haben
heiliger und und schnitt also dass das
ist hier keine quasi nationalistische
schild herum es ist muss der ursprung im
17 jahrhundert hat schon auf 17 und 18
jahrhundert hat schon eine gewisse
geografische ausprägung okay das ist
jetzt mit der kontinuität sache ich bin
leicht erkältet wir haben also noch ganz
schnell wieder zur politischen dimension
wir haben uns angeschaut das gibt mehr
oder weniger zum 3
standpunkt es gibt mit benjamin zu reden
dem sozialdemokratischen standpunkt das
heißt fortschrittsglaube zum klassischen
liberalismus john stuart mill und co der
glaube dass die menschen sich immer weil
besser organisieren und entwickeln und
das ergibt fortschritt und darauf kann
man sich verlassen auch als marx ist
auch wenn man der meinung ist dass das
proletariat momentan stark benachteiligt
ist trotzdem die gesellschaft entwickelt
sich und uns ins ins gute den guten
entgegen wird von benjamin sehr stark
kritisiert wie wir wissen hat überhaupt
nichts gebracht der faschismus ist über
europa ein gefallen und also der
fortschrittsglaube ist gescheitert gut
dann haben wir zwei aspekte zwei
elemente der diskontinuität das eine was
ihr gleich zu beginn uns angeschaut
haben quasi eine unvermittelte
diskontinuität ein richtiger sprung in
die neue welt und das ist entweder wie
bye lenin wo die politische klasse nicht
einfach warten bis etwas positives
kommen sondern schlicht und einfach die
macht ergreift kämpferisch das wird dann
übernommen oder gespiegelt bei bei
schmidt und anderen wo es auch einen
unvermittelten übergang gibt jetzt in
die in die neue zeit bei schmidt ist es
dann er rassistisch nationalistisch bei
heidegger bisschen abgemildert der
gedanke des schicksals quasi ein
schicksal durch kultur kultur geschichte
geprägt aber trotzdem ein unvermittelter
übergang und das ist jetzt bei bei
schmidt ganz besonders betont
wo wir ja diese sache mit dem führer
haben alles konzentriert sich auf den
führer die entscheidungen des führer
sind spontan nicht abgeleitet sondern
absolut originär von in dieser
originalität entsteht dann eben die neue
welt die so eine metapher hierfür ist
natürlich die metapher des erwachens
schlaf und erwachen deutschland erwache
slogan der
die nationalsozialisten das ist
natürlich ein bisschen problematisch
weil wir das auch bei benjamin finden
der auch die metaphorik von traum und er
waren bemüht in beiden fällen aber geht
es wie gesagt um die diskontinuität wenn
ich erwache aus dem schlaf bin ich nicht
mehr in dem kontinuität meines träumens
befangen sondern absolut frei
übrigens da natürlich auch fußnoten haft
genau dieses awakening ist etwas was die
trump anhänger in amerika inzwischen
jetzt auch bemühen
also man muss 60 mal sehr aufpassen mit
mit dieser metapher
aber wie auch immer das ist jetzt so
quasi der unvermittelte übergang aus dem
bösen aus der bösen alten zeit in die
neuzeit
wir haben aber auch bei benjamin gesehen
es gibt auch eine zweite einen zweiten
aspekt
das ist so quasi eine mischung aus
kontinuität und kontinuität und ich
würde das als konstruktivistisch
bezeichnen das finden wir bei benjamin
früher fanden wir es auch bei burg und
der gedanke dort ist dass man es ist
zwar ein bisschen über unvermittelter
übergang in eine bessere zeit aber
geleitet durch geprägt durch die
wiederaufnahme von historischen inhalten
es ist schon auch pragmatisch und das
ist bei benjamin ist es dieses ein
gedenken also ich bin ja das
da ist eine frage die frage ist werden
die letzten vorlesung von dezember noch
online gestellt ich sind online da ist
ein link auf der auf der homepage von
dieser veranstaltung ist ein link zu
beiden vorlesungen die ich per zu ende
des jahres gemacht habe das geht
natürlich nur wenn sie eingeschrieben
sind
aber das sind sie nämlich an sonst
werden sie gar nicht hier bei ok jetzt
wie gesagt also ich würde den den
begriff konstruktivistisch hier für
diese diese form des der diskontinuität
oder bisschen diskontinuität nehmen weil
es ein bewusster ein bewusstes auswählen
von den emanzipatorischen elementen der
vergangenheit also wie benjamins auch
das ist eine rache das ist die rache der
unterdrückten die sich dann jetzt zum
ausdruck bringt also es ist nicht
einfach unvermittelt das erwachen in
einem nationalistischen himmel oder
irgend sowas sondern es ist die reichen
der leiden der vergangenheit
diskontinuität aber ja eine pragmatische
konstruktive und man hofft letztendlich
romane
ein humaner vorgang und das erinnert
dann eben auch an burg und diese ganze
struktur der tradition wohl die
positiven elemente der tradition so
quasi zu fassen werden der unterdrückten
das ist dann wie sitzt jetzt
funktionieren soll
ok jetzt das mal wieder zur erinnerung
jetzt die frage leibnitz und metaphysik
also das ist jetzt ein bisschen
schwierig und anstrengend aber versuchen
wir das machen
ich habe texte von leibnitz wie immer
auch die homepage gesetzt wie sie wissen
leuten jetzt ist hat selber nicht auf
deutsch geschrieben sondern auch
französisch oder latein aber relativ
einfache sprache in beiden fällen also
das können sie sich anschauen auf der
haupt auf der homepage habe ich die
üblichen übersetzungen soweit vorhanden
verwendet aus der reklame ausgabe von
leighton exotischen schriften und dann
aus der größeren jährigen haring hering
ausgabe er war hat auch die reclam
ausgabe herausgegeben aber in beiden
fällen das sind seine übersetzungen okay
jetzt atom ismus und hier conti nun also
leiten jetzt konnte ist laut nutzens
begriff er betont die ganze zeit prinzip
der kontinuität ist das was seine seiner
philosophie von beispielsweise newton
oder hobbs unterscheidet und auch von
den kampf und das ist es was quasi dass
das neue bei ihm ist also wie sie wissen
leider zehn minuten haben beide
zur gleichen zeit mehr oder weniger
unabhängig voneinander die internet
rechnung erfunden und das jedenfalls
beileid netz führt zu einer darstellung
der realität die wie gesagt eher von
format eine einen unterschied prägt zum
atheismus der atom ist muss jedenfalls
nach lenzens darstellung geht davon aus
dass es die welt oder die erfahrung oder
die das universum aus einem großen
leeren raum besteht und in diesem raum
sind einzelne gegenstände substanzen die
voneinander unterschieden sind und
unteilbar sind das sind so kleine arte
gegen städte sozusagen stellt man sich
das vor
und diese arten gegenstände interagieren
miteinander
daher ist natürlich auch die sind die
gravitations schwerkraft theorie in van
noten hilfreich also es gibt lauter
beschreibungen wie diese gegenstände
miteinander kommunizieren oder oder oder
oder was passiert wenn sie
aufeinandertreffen
aber insgesamt ist die besteht die diese
welt aus einfach aus lehre aus leeren
raum es nicht nein es ist nicht nichts
weil es existieren der raum existiert
aber da ist nix drin und ist auch
neutral und nicht aktiv leibnitz dagegen
sagt er beschreibt die welt mit einer
dynamik also die dynamik bedeutet dass
alles was in der welt passiert im
universum miteinander verknüpft ist und
es sind nicht substanzielle gegen stimmt
die welt besteht nicht aus gegenständen
also wie gesagt atome genau wie man sich
das vorstellen kann atome sind und
teilbare ging stellen also sehr sehr
klein aber nicht mehr teilbar und diese
kleinen harten gegenstand das ist der
begriff der verwendet wird diese harte
gegenstände lässt das lässt sich jetzt
nicht mehr reduzieren das sind einfach
harte gegenstände im leeren raum und und
das ist weil sie die welt und das ist
auch etwas was durchaus plausibel sein
kann auch in der naturwissenschaft aber
das lehnt es jetzt ab und dem er sagt
nein es gibt keine und also vor allem
gibt es keine unteilbaren gegenstände
die vorstellung das ist so ganz kleinen
allerkleinste teile gibt die man nicht
mehr alle kleinste gegenstände atome die
man nicht mehr aufteilen kann also als
nicht haltbar
das ist schlicht und einfach falsch das
kommt so quasi von der von der falschen
richtung für leiden jetzt ist es
andersrum
also er sagt nicht punkte im leeren raum
sondern kraft dynamik und diese kraft
oder diese dynamik füllt den raum in dem
sinne dass der raum eigentlich gar nicht
also der raum ist ist nicht unabhängig
ist nicht neutral sondern ist ein teil
dieser kraft äußerung ja also die kraft
äußert sich entfaltet sich und braucht
dafür ihre raum und zeit also raum und
zeit sind dann die ordnungsprinzipien
für diese kraft sie sind nicht
unabhängig
es ist nicht so dass raum oder zeit
von vornherein und unabhängig von der
substanz existieren sondern die
substanzen entwickeln sich breiten sich
aus in raum und zeit und diese
substanzen sind orte der kraft
okay das lässt sich ganz gut mit der
institution rechnung veranschaulichen
aber ich habe ja ich versuche es mal
ganz kurz bin ja kein mathematiker aber
ich versuche es mal trotzdem also
koordinatensystem und da gehe also das
ist dann zeit und das ist sagen wir mal
ort und man kann gegen diese beiden
koordinaten die entwicklung eines
gegenstands also ist endlich vom
ausgangspunkt bewegt sich ein gegenstand
ein irgendwas in irgendeine richtung und
das ist jetzt die distanz vom
ausgangspunkt und das ist die zeit
ok also das ist jetzt eine möglichkeit
der darstellung aber wie sie wissen das
ist eine relativ primitiv und viel
interessanter wäre es wenn man
darstellen könnte oder sagen wir mal so
jeder punkt was ist die eigenschaft von
so einem punkt man kann sagen ja es ist
cm vom ausgangs von der ausgangsposition
entfernt und das ist nach fünf sekunden
was je nachdem was wir an diesen
koordinaten hat aber ist das jetzt eine
eigenschaft des punktes und ist das eine
interessante eigenschaft also insofern
kann man jetzt die gesamte geschichte
adäquat erfassen wenn man davon ausgehen
ja es ist einfach eine abfolge von
punkten das ist quasi das automatische
lernt man nicht besonders viel los dass
dieser darstellung
was die indizes imal rechnung macht wie
sie sicherlich von der schule noch
wissen ist dass die eigenschaften dieser
punkt als dynamische eigenschaften
erfasst werden indem man eine tangente
herstellt und an diesem punkt wo die
tangente die kurve berührt hat man eine
information über diesen punkt aber mehr
als sie bei dem punkt über über die
kurve insgesamt das wäre dann die
geschwindigkeit und das geht dann
natürlich weiter da kann man als
weiteres mittel die geschwindigkeit auch
noch gegen die zeitachse definieren oder
aufzeichnen und dann davon eben auch
noch eine tangente ziehen und dann haben
wir die beschleunigung und das also das
ist jetzt das ziel aber um eine
kalkulationsbasis davon zu schaffen wie
sie wissen muss man hier an dieser
stelle davon ausgehen können dass die
kurve infinity mal klein ist also wenn
man das jetzt vergrößert ist die kurve
immer noch gebogen und was soll man
jetzt über eine gebogene kurve sagen
also das ist zunächst mal ein problem
aber die technik wie sie wissen ist dass
man diese kurve immer noch immer weiter
einengt dass man weil sie einen
grenzwert hat in der mitte das ohne
ausdehnung ist aber trotzdem einmal eine
dynamische eigenschaft ja okay also ich
denke dass alles wie sie besser als ich
aber der clou dabei ist der gedanke dass
man immer noch immer das land dieses
diesen ausgedienten pumpt immer kleiner
machen kann und zwar ohne ende
ja also die die kurve ist unendlich
teilbar und behält trotzdem diese
eigenschaft von geschwindigkeit oder
beschleunigung oder was auch immer
also man kann immer noch auch bei einer
absolut unteilbaren oder internet
unendlich geteilten kursen abschnitt
trotzdem eine tangente herstellen und
damit eben diese informationen
herausziehen gut also das argument bei
leiden ist dass das ist jetzt nicht
also was das zeigt vielleicht ist das
wenn ich mit kraft und unendlicher
teilbarkeit beginnen kann ich alles
beschreiben was ich bisher versucht habe
zu beschreiben mit punktuellen
darstellung aber ich kann dann auch
vielmehr beschreiben
ja das ist der punkt also unendlich
geteilt ein punkt ich nähere mich einem
infiniti mal kleinen
punkt kann trotzdem über diesen punkt
mal sagen über den punkt ansonsten also
wenn ich diese technik nicht verwendet
kann ich nicht sagen also ich kann
jedenfalls nicht sagen dass jetzt eine
bestimmte geschwindigkeit oder eine
bestimmte beschleunigung aber sonst kann
ich kann nur sagen ja ok nach fünf
sekunden zehn meter entfernung vom
ausgang des von der ausgangsposition das
ist dann eben relativ okay aber mit der
dynamischen erklärung sagt leibnitz kann
ich eben die dynamik darstellt und das
ist weil es wichtig ist oder sagen wir
anders und es ist nicht nur eine
praktische frage sondern ich nähere mich
dann dem wesen des 1 das ist es sein ist
eben dynamisch für leighton ist und das
ist der grund warum ich jetzt mit einer
solchen kalkulation adecco hat man sagen
kann
und daraus folgt beispielsweise oder
erfolgt viel ist aber er sagt zum
beispiel aus dem kontinuität gesetzt
also kontinuität ist die möglichkeit
jede kurve unendlich zu komprimieren
sozusagen ich nähere mich einen bogen
durch dieses verkleinern oder teilen
oder was auch immer das ist die
kontinuität also kontinuität ist keine
atome atome ist in einzelnen punkten
soll
aber die kontinuität ist wo ich auch die
punkte verzichten kann die punkte sind
nur grenzwerte drinnen sich diese die
kontinuität immer näher
ohne aber dann in einem punkt aufzugehen
ja okay und deswegen kann er sagen das
habe ich auf der
zitatensammlung man kann die phänomene
die mana touristisch als ausgangspunkte
betrachter kann dann mit dieser dynamik
als abgeleitet darstellen und zwar viel
besser als wenn man wenn man als
minister geht also der der atom ist
beginnt mit punkten und einzelnen
gegenständen und so weiter dann versucht
sie zusammen zu bauen
das ist aber falsch sagt ereignet womit
ich beginnen soll ist die kraft ist die
kraft und die dynamik und wenn ich die
kraft und den die dynamik die
kontinuierlich arbeitet also kraft hat
keinen ort oder jedenfalls bereitet sich
die kraft aus in jedem ort und ist nicht
beschränkt auf einen punkt oder eine
substanz oder stück materie oder
sonstwas sondern ist halt ist halt kraft
und diese kraft kann nicht beschreiben
mit beispielsweise der infiniti mal
rechnung so lange ich darauf verzichte
unbedingt punkte definieren zu wollen
und deswegen sagt diatonischen
physikalischen phänomene wie
beispielsweise ruhe oder gleichheit kann
ich aus der dynamik ableiten
indem ich sie definiere also wie gesagt
das ist das sind dann diese dieser
punkte sind für die internet erstmal
rechnung grenzwerte wo sich die größe
nährt aber nicht aufgeht und deswegen
sagte dass kontinuität gesetzt aufgrund
dessen man die ruhe als eine unendlich
kleine bewegung betrachten kann ja also
ich fange der bewegung achten an die
sache unter den entsprechenden umständen
grimms wert haben wir ruhe aber das ist
einfach infiniti sie mal betrachtet
keine bewegung
sehr wenig bewegung unendlich wenig
bewegung
ja zum beispiel untersagt koinzidenz
also identität des ortes ist eine
unendlich kleine entfernung
es ist nicht einfach quasi da zwei
gegenstände zusammen oder irgendwas
sondern die es ist eine dynamisch
erklärte entfernung die unendlich klein
ist ja ok und das wiederum ist für
leighton jetzt die basis für da sein
denken das klassische es ist die
unendlichkeit also container ist
unendlichkeit unteilbarkeit oder restlos
teilbarkeit also unendliche teilbarkeit
ist die das wesen dieser dynamik in der
dynamik ist bewegung und die bewegung
ist das wurzel die wurzel des des seins
nicht das nicht nicht dass stehen da
stehen der gegenstand okay okay und
übrigens also in diesem zusammenhang
weil alles unendlich teilbar ist sagt
leibnitz auch die folge daraus ist dass
alles quasi die gesamte gewann gesamte
universum in sich enthalten kann
ja es ist ein etwas schwierig aber ich
habe mir das unbedingt brauchen
im politischen bereich aber der gedanke
ist wie gesagt also weil die kraft
unendlich ist und auch unendlich teilbar
ist ist die kraft überall und alle
gegenstände enthalten
das komplette universum im sich
zumindest weisen sie darauf hin und dann
ist es das schöne bild ich weiß nicht ob
sie den film men in black einander ist
diese das bekannte stelle wo die katze
eine halskette anhalt mit einem so einen
globus
und da stellt sich heraus dass in diesem
globus eine galaxie enthalten ist also
eine richtige galaxie quasi und der film
taucht diese galaxie auf und da ist
jetzt wieder eine eine unendliche breite
des seins in dieser diesem in dieser
halskette dass der katze weiß nicht ob
ihnen das sie macht aber sie kennen wenn
sie den film gesehen haben dann wissen
sie was ich meine
das ist das ist ein leiden ins tal
gedanke also ob die
leute die jemanden men in black gedreht
haben davon der vorstellung hat weiß ich
nicht aber das ist ebenfalls ein genau
das von leuten jetzt denkt und er sagt
auch in diesen französischen zitat auf
seite 2 mein name exzerpte das ist sorry
hab ich geschrieben aktuellen chip
division genie sorry also meine
französische aussprache ist katastrophal
aber dass auch das kleinste körper auch
der kleinste körper ist unterteilbar
unendlich unterteilbar und ihr mut den
novell kreatur und enthält eine ganze
welt von neuen kreaturen also hatte halt
sagt irgendwo anders
das werden wir dann entdecken wenn wir
entsprechende mikroskope haben oder die
möglichkeit haben diese sehr kleinen
phänomene zu erforschen
ja gut also nightmares gedanke ist dann
also dass durch dieses das kontinuum das
nicht heilbar ist das nicht irgendwie
von gegenstand zur gegenstand stottert
das kontinuierlich sondern es ist eine
eine gesamt mich an diese sind nämlich
an
wahrscheinlich ist also jedenfalls ein
phänomen wo alles in diese in diese
kraft und diese entwicklung ein beton
wird gut und da haben wir auch andere
elemente die aus seiner philosophie
bekannt sind
er sagt jetzt in diesem weiteren
abschnitten es gibt also seine gegner
die atom ist muss sagen es gibt schon
leere bereiche also einfach wo gar nix
ist nein sagt leuten uns das kann nicht
sein weil alles ist durchtränkt von der
von der dynamik es gibt also keine
lücken und das wichtig der wichtigste
punkt mit dieser mit diesem dieser
abwesenheit von lücken ist sein satz vom
zureichenden gründe
das ist ja sehr bekannt sagt also
bleiben jetzt gibt es in der metaphysik
zwei logische setzte der erste satz ist
die zahl ist ist der satz von seiner
identität kann nicht gleichzeitig nicht
da sein und darauf sagt lloyd netz was
gewissermaßen auf stimmt kann man
jedenfalls die arithmetik aufbauen und
der zweite punkt wo es um die konkrete
metaphysische feld ist ist der satz vom
zu gleichen grunde und der satz vom zu
erreichen dem grund ist eine ausprägung
davon dass es keine lücken gibt ja weil
alles ist in der event in der
selbstentfaltung der kraft hängt alles
miteinander zusammen
und das heißt alles was erfolgt bewirkt
dann auch weitere folgen
das ist für die automessen nicht der
fall also bei den anatomischen kann es
sein dass irgendwas geschieht und dann
dann auch nichts mehr
es gibt keine zwingende kausale relation
zwischen den ereignissen
das ist beileibe nicht der fall bei
leibnitz ist es die kontinuierliche das
kontinuierliche universum ist in allen
bereichen miteinander verknüpft bis ins
kleinste also wie mit diese diese
infinite teilbarkeit und dann dazu hat
diesen ausdruck dass die gegenwärtig mit
der zukunft schwanger geht und dass und
jeder gegebene zustand ist nur durch den
unmittelbar vorausgehenden auf
natürliche weise erklärbar also alles
hat einen grund also nicht dass wir
immer den grund wissen aber jedenfalls
hat alle ist ein grund und das ist die
aufgabe der wissenschaft der philosophie
diese gründe zu ergründen
wenn man das nicht hat sagt ja und das
ist jetzt gegen die die automessen
gerichtet wenn man das nicht
postuliert als als engagement tisch dann
muss man um die erklärungen gibt es im
internet erklären zu können
zitat zu wundern oder zum bloßen zufall
zuflucht nehmen ja das mag auf keinen
fall also wunder oder oder zufall das
ist etwas was der autor ist zu lassen
kann ein neuer code also mal passiert
mal passiert nicht das ist es ist nicht
entscheidend
und oft so der der atom ist
hat er also wie leighton ist da sagt in
dem zuflucht zu wundern und haben gut
also ich kann nicht erklären wie das
gekommen ist muss halt ein wunder
gewesen sein da hat gott intervenieren
ja gut also das ist jetzt auch ein bild
oder ein topos der dann natürlich auch
im 18 jahrhundert weiter kontrovers
bleibt wie sie wissen dass findet seine
eine weitere ausprägung in der
kontroverse zwischen tanz und juden wo
jung oder zuerst natürlich war nicht
direkt eine kontroverse aber jedenfalls
ganz kritik an hier um jung sagt
qualität das ist nur was subjektiv ist
was wir den phänomenen unterstellen und
kann schafft nein das kann nicht sein
also kausalität ist eine eine bedingung
der erkenntnis und ich kann nicht ohne
kausalität arbeiten also ob das den
dingen an sich zukommt oder die ist eine
andere frage aber bekannt ist kausalität
unverzichtbar in der rational erkenntnis
der welt also hier kann auch im
wesentlichen auf einer lite mädchen
position und der anderen seite jung so
ein bisschen fortführen
die gedanken von hobbes und und den atom
ist okay und dass deswegen sagt leiten
jetzt jedenfalls das hatten wir schon
nicht mehr leben es jetzt nochmal also
der gedanke einläuten lehrerin leere
räume gibt es nicht
also das ist sagt dass in das ist dieser
gedanke ist in das reich der träume zu
verweisen
leere räume sind ein traum das gibt es
einfach nicht alles ist miteinander
verknüpft alles was passiert geschieht
aus
als wirkung von etwas voraus gegangen
und und beeinflusst dann entsprechend
das was vor ort und es gibt keine lehre
zeit und keine leeren raum alles ist
dass es beide sind nur eine darstellung
der wirklichkeit und das ist natürlich
wesentlichen auch kann's gehen mit der
transzendentalen ästhetik geraumer zeit
das alles ordnungsprinzip
er sagt jetzt sagt les bas also raumnot
regisseur seth gordon rapp medien
nicole keller possibile damit also ist
ist nur dieses dieses ordnungsprinzip 3
uhr ab
in der dtm ist sonst überhaupt längst
ohne die körper die in diesen raum oder
in dieser zeit eingesetzt werden ok also
wie gesagt transzendentale ästhetik
jetzt letzter metaphysische der letzte
metaphysische punkt bei beileid nimmt
auch sehr charakteristisch die atom ist
in sagen ja die welt ist voll von dieser
harten gegenständen die nicht
miteinander kombinieren sondern für sich
eigenständig sind und im leeren raum
herumschwirren
nein sagt oder war mehr drin die ich
sagen mehr als dass sie sagen auch also
diese diese gegenstände
sind voneinander unterscheidbar
gegebenenfalls nur dadurch dass sie an
anderen orten sind die sind das ist die
numerische unterscheidung es kann zwei
gegenstände geben also atome oder auch
größere gegenstände die identisch sind
aber mit dem mit dem einzigen
unterschied dass sie an verschiedenen
stellen sind also beispielsweise hier in
diesem raum gibt es diverse tische man
könnte sagen der einzige unterschied
zwischen dem einen tisch und dem
nächsten tisch ist dass die an
verschiedenen stellen stehen ort mäßig
verschiedenste das ist das einzige sonst
sind die identisch leiten jetzt
kritisiert das und sagt nein die renten
der rein numerische unterschied den
rhein und numerischen unterschied gibt
es nicht weil alle unterschiede
begrifflich sind ja und begriffs ist
mehr als nur platz also ort ist nicht
begriff ort ist nur wie gesagt der
rahmen in dem ich diese diese substanzen
wahrnehme aber die eigentliche
unterscheidung win win zwei gegenstände
von einander tatsächlich unterschieden
sind dann kann ich die begriffliche
unterscheiden indem ich sage ja farbe
ist verschiedenen gewicht ist
verschieden
auf dem einen tisch ist weg oder man
dann ist es sauber oder irgendwas also
das sind lauter begriffliche
unterschiede und leiten
das ist immer der fall also rein
numerische unterschiede gibt es nicht
und das ist der punkt das ist auch
wieder das gesetz der kontinuität dass
die gesamte welt durchdrungen ist von
diesem begrifflichkeiten ja also die
welt ist nicht
ein leerer raum ihre zeit mit ein paar
objekten trennen sondern eine durch
durchdrungene kraft und in dieser kraft
diese kraft differenziert sich
begrifflich nicht einfach weil so passiv
ja da ist was und hier ist was und
deswegen center unterschieden und daher
bringt er diese bilder die sehr bekannt
sind
wo er sagt er hätte sich im park
aufgehalten mit seiner mit der einen
moment wie war das jetzt die led die die
elektrisch die kurfürsten von hannover
ich glaube es ist wahr die tochter von
diesem englischen fürsten oder die die
enkel leben von dem ich weiß dass jetzt
nicht mehr jederzeit eine eine dame mit
der leibniz also unter anderem geben da
waren etliche philosophisch
interessierte hatte liegt mit leuten zu
tun hatten und also bei einem gespräch
ging es darum also der der gegner also
quasi der atom ist der dabei war hat
gesagt ja das kann doch nicht sein dass
die sachen die gegenstände sich nur über
begriffe oder immer über begriffe
unterscheiden lassen und dann ist es
okay finden hier ein paar blätter
aus hier aus dem garten die identisch
sind
die in der form in den in der
ausgehenden fahrbericht uns weiter fort
und das konnte ich nicht also jedes auch
die kleinsten blätter auch wenn tausende
im herbst herumliegen auf dem rasen
es ist unmöglich zwei blätter zu finden
die nur sich dadurch unterscheiden dass
es eben zwei sind und nicht umsonst
sondern sie sind begrifflich
unterschrieben und dann sagt er auch das
gleiche gilt zwei wassertropfen gute gut
du also wassertropfen oder milch topfen
wenn man sie mit einem mikroskop das ist
auch noch tippfehler mikroskop
untersucht dann wird man auch sehen dass
die unterschiede also ein wassertropfen
geschieht natürlich aus wie ein anderer
wassertropfen aber wenn ich jetzt in die
details gehen mit einem mikroskop
dann werde ich schon feststellen dass
das dass die beiden wassertropfen die
mir vorliegen sich durch
begrifflichkeiten unterscheiden ok und
das ist dann sagte sie grob resources
ltd das dessert nabu also die identität
der nicht unterscheidbaren das ist auch
ein teil von diesem hype mäzens weltbild
wo quasi alles durch dieses diese diese
begriffliche rational
vor die sich überall in der welt im
großen wie auch in mikroskopisch kleinen
entfaltet und uns eine wirklichkeit
darstellt ok also das ist jetzt ich
meine für uns heute ist das vielleicht
nicht so wahnsinnig überzeugend aber es
war extrem einflussreich wie gesagt also
die parallelen zwischen leute nutzen
kann sind sehr deutlich und wichtiger
ist eben dass das eine position ist die
durchaus auch quasi einiges erklärt mit
der kontinuität also man wenn man
schmidt oder oder nietzsche oder
benjamin liste würde man denken ja wer
kommt überhaupt darauf dass die welt ein
kontinent darstellt
die antwort ist nicht nur das historisch
die kontinuität durchaus plausibel und
überzeugend den den del den denkern
programm sondern auch immer noch
eigentlich die standard position wäre
also die wenn man sagt ja die welt ist
eigentlich eine hochkomplexe maschine re
wo der mensch sicherlich interveniert
aber letztendlich sind auch diese
interventionen geprägt durch
rationalität und deswegen ist eben eine
kontinuität also immer man kann auch
nach heutigen vorstellungen nicht ohne
weiteres einen ort ausmachen wo
metaphysisch diskontinuität
herrscht insofern ist laut netz auch
wenn er jetzt vielleicht ein bisschen
übertrieben metaphysischen und
optimistisch klingt für heute durchaus
eine wichtige quelle für diesen
gedankengang und in vielerlei hinsichten
vielleicht auch überzeugender als diese
faszination mit dem sprung eben es
unvermittelt neue die wir uns
vorgenommen oder uns angeschaut uns
anschauen
ok also ich das ist jetzt das was ich zu
sagen wollte gibt es da zu vertragen
übrigens ich habe jetzt vergessen dass
aufzunehmen aber das ist nicht so
schlimm weil die frau bereits
aufgenommen und das wird dann auf der
homepage erscheinen also der normalen
homepage ist auch ein normaler weil ich
wollte eigentlich das op zoom aufnehmen
kommt es aber nicht gemacht insofern
sind sie alle schön anonym
wenn sie das bleiben wollen wenn sie
jetzt eine frage stellen wollen dann
können sie das entweder akustisch oder
ich kann es dann vorlesen und
aja moment erwarten sie malt das ist mit
das ist zu leise da höre ich nichts ok
versuchen wir ja ja ja in dem fall ja ja
ja ja ich verstehe ich schon was jemand
okay das mache ich also ich würde nur
sagen also einer kommilitonin ist es
schon gelungen da reinzukommen
ich weiß zwar nicht wie aber die hat
dann zurückgeschrieben ja es sei ihr
gelungen den link auf zu machen aber
okay ich verstehe schon was sie was sie
meinen ich jeweils mir dann später
anschauen
lsf ich meine es aber heute wird dann
der
département page stehen ja bitte
ok also wenn wenn es keine fragen gibt
[Musik]
dann auch weil ich ein bisschen erkältet
bin würde ich die veranstaltung
schließen
ok